this morning Russia's government
admitted that mistakes have been made in
the mobilization of some 300 000 Reserve
troops for the war in Ukraine meantime
protests are still going on all across
that country with many draftees refusing
to go and predictably Russia's police
are cracking down on dissent Deborah
patta has the latest now from Ukraine
Vladimir Putin may not be bluffing about
using weapons of mass destruction but
Vladimir zielinski says while that might
be true it is blackmail we spoke briefly
with the Ukrainian leader in a rare
private moment inside his presidential
office turned bunker as Ukraine becomes
more successful Russia is getting more
desperate sham elections conscription
and non-nuclear threats we forget or for
God what does it mean to be afraid of
Russia and we don't afraid them I'm
afraid each day about how long people
have to wait us when we'll come when
we'll come back back to our to our
country to our land and to the occupied
in a desperate attempt to staunch losses
on the battlefield Putin has called up
thousands of military reservists
resulting in widespread anti-war
protests
the call has been so unpopular this man
opened fire at a recruitment center
wounding an officer in this video a
commander tells disgruntled new
conscription to shut up and stop acting
like women your soldiers now he shouts
the games are over young men continue to
stream across the border to dodge the
draft zielinski has appealed to them to
defy the call up or Surrender promising
over the weekend they will be treated
humanely and not return to Russia they
are not soldiers Russians it's not about
soldiers it's about terrorism Putin
needs a win in his War he's desperately
trying to Ram through a vote to Annex
occupied territory seized in Ukraine
staging polls in a gruesome Distortion
of democracy amid the rubble and ruins
of War election officials accompanied by
armed soldiers bang on Doors
searching for voters the residents of
towns and Villages seized with bullets
now being asked to respond by Rubber
stamping ballots
[Music]
Russia's foreign minister has bluntly
said they're entitled to use nuclear
weapons to defend newly annexed
territories the White House says if
Russia crosses the line there will be
catastrophic consequences Nate
Deborah Potter and Ukraine thank you